taylor swift broke this news my brand
new album comes out october 21st
oh look what you made me do
tay not only smashed vma records with
the most video of the year wins but she
also broke twitter with that veiled kim
yay swipe october 21st
[Applause]
yeah fans noticed october 21st is also
kim k's 42nd birthday oh and last night
marked her favorite number 13 years
since this infamous kanye moment
when swift posted her artwork for
midnight she captioned that it was quote
the stories of 13 sleepless nights
scattered throughout my life
inside taylor posed with kane brown he
wasn't her date neither was joe alwyn
instead it was cinematographer rina yang
the dancing pair worked on her all too
well music video which picked up three
of five awards but who really got taylor
groovin
[Applause]
[Music]
even though nikki was co-hosting the
michael jackson video vanguard recipient
who was twerking and dancing backstage
didn't appear until 55 minutes in
thanking your son and kanye west beyonce
madonna mariah carey eminem britney
spears fellow co-host jack harlow open
the show taking flight
and taking us back with this glamorous
surprise
fergie
congratulations
jack who won four awards hugged it out
with fergie and gave her a shout out
thank you to fergie for coming out with
me tonight and clearing this song
hey you know what
i needed the work
and yeah that's a virtual johnny depp
making several brief cameos and joking
less than three months after winning his
50 million dollar defamation suit
against ex amber heard i'm available for
birthdays
today amber's sister whitney blasted the
stunt posting quote mtv you're
disgusting and clearly desperate back to
the music can country star kane brown's
history making grant performance
the first male country artist performing
at the vmas
i feel good you know i'm kind of upset
that i'm not singing a country song
kane's new song grand is one of two pup
tracks set to appear on his upcoming
album different man so that begs the
question will there ever come a time
when you transition entirely into the
pop genre i'll never just transition
straight up
lizzo preach her message of self love on
stage
during her video for good acceptance
speech lizzo also delivered a drop to
mike response seemingly to comedian
aries spears offensive comments on her
weight they'd be like lizzie why don't
you clap back why don't you clap back
because i'm winning this mtv mtv dawg we
got a show
only e.t was backstage moments before
eminem and snoop dogg took audiences on
a trip into the metaverse for their
first collab in more than 20 years
[Applause]
global icon award recipients the red hot
chili peppers dedicated their award to
late foo fighters drummer taylor hawkins
i miss him every day and uh fly on hawk
play him brother
so your first vmas how did it feel to be
out there on that electrifying stage it
was sick i mean we are really happy to
have the chance to perform i was
backstage with italian glam rock band
mana skin just after bearing a ton of
skin on stage
[Music]
but it was basis victoria de angelis's
wardrobe malfunction that triggered
sensors to cut to a wide shot of the
audience
only e.t was with first time winners
former disney star dove cameron and
international superstar anita i'm fully
sobbing no
i am i'm really shocked i'm gonna put it
in my bed i'm gonna sleep with it
i'm on a sleep pedal
bad bunny who is the biggest streaming
artist in the world yes even bigger than
beyonce one artist of the year it nearly
broke the internet after kissing a man
and woman during his performance
of course the vma excitement didn't end
there we got plenty of stars to dish
like joel madden talking family life
with nicole richie she is the judge on
making the cuts and he's revamping
inkmaster on paramount floods are things
highly competitive at home now our our
family is a competition show so our kids
have to compete for our love so um it's
really healthy for them it's good
would you guys ever do a reality show on
your family uh no nicole you know many
years ago she had that show you know
that show
my kids are not they're not down they
would be so embarrassed if we had if we
were on a show together they'd be
embarrassed
it is date night here in new jersey
late night every night in my house
real housewives of new jersey stars joe
and melissa gorga were out representing
their hometown but why they rsvp regrets
to sister theresa judice's wedding three
weeks ago it's very difficult for me to
talk about it's hard it's very real
really it's really hard
it's a rough situation it really is and
you know what i think everyone will
see obviously because a lot of it was
filmed for the real housewives but we
wish them the best and we're very happy
and she looked beautiful and it was a
beautiful wedding
dixie dimelio arrived solo and played
coy about rumors her sister charlie and
mom heidi are heading to the dancing
with the stars dance floor i cannot
confirm or deny this information
[Music]
drink of water baby you already know
what it is
but bringing the heat to the red carpet
26 year old rapper young gravy in his
date 42 year old sherry easterling aka
tick talker addison ray's mom what is
the obsession with
they're more experienced they are
an under service community what is it
about young gravy
he's very wholesome i would say
believe it or not i am a wholesome
person i am a wholesome